Come on, Nomikoto-chan, we
're both on the same ride 6 lifetimes There's no need to weigh the whereabouts of the clones and the lives of the two of
us I'll ask you once, what about my sisters
I'll say it
again  Either you think you're against it, or you're abandoning one or the other
I'll
help Mr.
vr.
If you have a grudge, No. 3 c Mikoto-cha
[music]
If you're
a descendant of Mikoto, there's no abnormality in your breathing, pulse, or body
.
You can hear it from
Mr.
W.I.A.R.I.E.A.R.I.E.A.R.I.A.N.I.E.A.R.I.A.N.A.A.I.A.N.A.I.A.I.A.R.I.E.A  Oh, oh
, metal doesn't work Kuroko teleports two people in Angela
[music]
I didn't even listen to the play I
can blow you away with l 1
[music]
But ah
[applause]